in the 1970s one six foot nine inch tall
man named Edmund Kemper towered over his
peers and most considered him to be a
gentle giant no one in his life could
have imagined that he would murder six
teenage girls hitchhiking through Santa
Cruz California or that he would finally
turn his rage on his own mother no one
in kembers life ever got any bad vibes
and he didn't show many signs that there
was anything wrong he ashleighb had a
genius-level IQ and he was the kind of
person you could imagine having a
fascinating conversation with over a cup
of coffee
he was so likable indeed that no one
would have ever guessed that he could be
capable of killing a total of 10 people
and defiling their corpses he covered
his tracks so thoroughly that he would
never have been caught either until he
picked up a pay phone and turned himself
in
today on biographic s-- we're talking
about Edmund Kemper the co-ed killer
[Music]
Edmund Kemper was born in 1948 in
Burbank California he was a very
sensitive and intelligent boy like many
families at that time Ed's parents
raised chickens and grew their own
vegetables in the backyard Eadie
idolized his father and he loved to
spend time with the chickens and the
other farm animals as if they were his
pets he gave them all names and played
games with them in the backyard
his mother was always quick to reprimand
and discipline him so he was always a
very well-behaved child he had two
sisters one older and one younger who
received more love and attention from
their mother ed was still in primary
school when his father dropped two of
the chickens heads off in front of him
later of course his mother would cook
the birds for dinner when he refused to
eat his pants his parents shouted at him
over the dining table forcing him to eat
the chicken through his tears that night
he got on his bike and he rode as far
away as he could but he would find that
there was no escape his father would
slowly force him to get over a
sensitivity of watching animals killed
as time went on he grew numb to the
blood and the headings and he learned to
accept it as just a part of life
ed later went on to kill a cat he
couldn't understand why the adults in
his life were telling him the killing
farm animals was acceptable but killing
a dog or a cat was simply not his
parents got a divorce when he was nine
years old but his mother was so bitter
that she began to take all of her hatred
out on it she said that all men were
worthless and she began to treat ed far
worse than his sister's simply because
he was a boy she moved them to Montana
and she got remarried the second
marriage it didn't work out either and
his mother went through a string of
boyfriends that never lasted very long
as a male role model as a child being
raised by a now single mother they did
not have a lot of toys so they would use
their imagination instead ed read a lot
of books from the librarians included in
his reading horrific stories from
history from the Vikings to the
Holocaust he's arrested that he and his
younger sisters could play a game called
the gas chamber they tied each other up
in a chair just to see you get
themselves out of the bondage the
quickest pretending that they were stuck
in a room that was four
with deadly gas his mother and sisters
had bedrooms upstairs and Ed once had
slept in a bedroom upstairs as well but
his mother decided to move his bedroom
down to the basement she was convinced
that he would hurt his sister's instead
of a bed he had to sleep on a cot with a
sleeping bag with only a single light
bulb hanging from a string it was damp
cold and frightening with only the rats
to keep him company at night
according to him he interpreted that his
mother had a deeper meaning behind her
actions he said why am I going to the
basement I'm going to hell they're going
to heaven
[Music]
ed was incredibly tall for his age so
everyone assumed that he was older than
he actually was he started driving when
he was only 10 years old this was
totally illegal of course but his mother
must have allowed him to use the family
car one day he drove himself to a
carnival and there was an attraction
where people could slide the head into a
real guillotine and pretend to have
their heads cut off ed saw it as a
strange contradiction that people were
laughing and squealing in the face of
death just for the thrill of it even
though it was all just pretend ed Kemper
he got excited and found himself wishing
that it was actually real it was in this
moment that his delusions began to get
far worse and he actually began having
difficulty deciphering what was real and
what was fantasy a 13 years old life at
home with his mother became so toxic
that he ran away from home to try and
live with his father runs his new
stepmother in Los Angeles but the
reunion would only last a couple of
months because he sent her to live with
his parents on their 17 acre farm his
grandparents lived in a remote location
on the top of a mountain surrounded by
their massive farmlands he was
completely isolated from the outside
world here his grandmother was just as
domineering and abusive as his mother
and his grandfather he had dementia
since they lived on so much land his
grandparents would allow him to use a
rifle to hunt rabbits squirrels and
raccoons his grandmother would carry the
guns with her whenever she left the
house for a year and a half things were
going fine until ed went back to see his
mother for the first time in almost two
years she knew exactly which buttons to
press to make him feel worthless being
around his mother triggered his
delusions to come back and any progress
he made in his mental health it was lost
upon returning to his grandparents
he slipped back into a delusional mental
state he pretended to leave the house
and then he shot his grandmother in the
back of the head with his rifle then he
killed his grandfather saying that he
did not want him to live through the
pain of knowing that his wife was
murdered during a later interview at
Kemper said that it was a good thing
that he was so isolated from society on
the farm because he was so angry at the
world in that moment that he knows he
would have become a mass murderer when
installation was over reality set in and
ed saw his grandparents were bleeding on
the floor he could have driven far away
from the scene and no one would have
known about their deaths for an
incredibly long time but the first thing
he did was call his mother he told her
what happens and she told him to call
the sheriff and turn himself in so he
did when police showed up to arrest him
he went willingly when he was asked for
an explanation he answered I wanted to
see what it would be like to kill
grandma since he was 15 when he killed
his grandparents ed Kemper was still
considered a minor and he went to a
mental hospital without having to serve
any jail time doctors gave him multiple
tests and they discovered that he had a
genius-level IQ and he was diagnosed
with paranoid schizophrenia at Kemper
they actually loved living in the
hospital because he was finally getting
the help that he so deeply needed
he took the proper medication and there
was a lot of structure and stability in
his life his mind began to heal and he
was fully in touch with reality for the
first time in a long time
he was even given a job shadowing one of
the doctors because they believed that
he could get better and that he would
still have a bright future ahead of him
this meant he was able to remain calm
and give the answers that the doctors
wanted to hear when they interviewed him
they were convinced that he had made a
full recovery and they set him free
after four years while he was in custody
he told his doctors all about the abuse
that he had endured from his mother as a
child and he begged for them not to send
him back to live with her his doctors
promised him that this would not happen
and they agreed that living with her
would only make his mental health worse
but the judge ultimately had the final
say and Heba dad Kemper back into his
mother's custody now that he was a
full-grown adult he grew to be a six
foot nine inch tall man he was so huge
that yet too dark in order to get into a
room he spent his childhood being
raised by conservative adults and all of
his teenage years were spent in a mental
hospital so ed Kemper he was shocked to
be thrust into the free love movement in
the hippie cultural revolution that was
happening in California he felt very
awkward and uncomfortable and could
barely hold a conversation with a girl
he was 21 years old when he first went
out on a date
he took a girl to Denny's and a John
Wayne movie bus nor felt incredibly
awkward he didn't smoke party didn't
listen to music or go to parties like
most kids of his age in the 1960s and
70s his mother had raised him saying
that all men were awful people and she
worked at the University of California
Santa Cruz with female students in many
ways his mother was a third wave
feminist who truly did despise men
having this shoved in his face on a
regular basis made Kemper Project his
hate towards his mother on to other
women he had fantasies about being with
women but he didn't have fantasies about
being in a relationship
[Music]
at Kemper decided that he wanted to
become a police officer because there
was a lot of structure and order in that
profession and it would be a good and
steady job oddly enough there wasn't his
juvenile record that stopped him from
becoming an officer his record had been
expunged so it was as if it had never
happened at all it was actually his
height that stopped him since there was
a limit on how tall a police officer
could be he decided that if he couldn't
get a job as an officer he still wanted
to be friends with cops and he started
hanging out with the police at a bar
called the jury room he found a job for
the california highway departments after
getting out of prison and for a short
while he and his own apartment since an
independent life away from his mother
but when he fell into financial hardship
he was stuck living with her again they
would often get into intense arguments
that made a situation worse on a daily
basis ed drove and drove and drove he
took up a habit of picking up
hitchhikers and giving them rides this
was very common back in the 1960s and
70s and college students held up signs
saying the location of where they wanted
to go in his mind yet this fantasy of
killing a young woman that he would pick
up he would practice picking up both men
and female hitchhikers and letting them
go free he did this over a hundred and
fifty times just as practice runs so
that he could feel prepared for any
scenario at the bar he was listening
very closely to what police officers
were saying about their new cases and
they mentioned the fact that teenage
girls ran away over time only to show up
sometime later in his mind he was living
out a fantasy where he would pick up a
girl so that he could rape and murder
her through all of these practice
conversations he figured out what to do
in order to make people feel more at
ease
he also concocted a plan to drop a
chapstick into the passenger door so
that his victims tried to escape they
could no longer open the door from the
inside his fantasy was finally realized
on May the 7th 1972 when he picked up to
18 year old girls named mary ann pesce
and anita lucius are in berkeley
california they asked for a ride to
Stanford University he drove them to a
secluded area in the woods and locked
Anita in the trunk he stabbed and
strangled Mary Ann before opening the
trunk and killing Anita in the same way
after they were dead he rapes them and
stuffed their bodies into the trunk of
his Ford Galaxie on the drive home a
police officer pulled him over he was
able to remain calm as if nothing had
happened the officer told him that his
taillight was out and he went on his way
he
dismembered their bodies put them into
bags and dumped these bags miles apart
in order to throw the police off
universities in the local area began to
tell their students not to accept rides
from strangers
they also told everyone that if they had
no choice but to accept a ride to only
get into cars with a campus sticker on
it ironically ed Kemper actually did
have one of these stickers from UC Santa
Cruz senses mother worked for the
college on September the 14th 1972 he
picked up a 15 year old girl named Aiko
Koo who needed a ride to a ballet class
and he killed her in the same fashion on
January the 7th of 1973 he killed Cindy
shawl instead of disposing of Cindy's
remains like he had done with the others
he buried her head in the yard
facing towards his mother's bedroom
window Cindy's head was actually sitting
in the trunk of his car when he went to
his state mandated therapy session his
psychiatrist was convinced that he was
better and they released him from the
court order to continue therapy even
though he kills months apart
ed Kemper continued to give rides to
young women on a regular basis just so
that he could get information about what
the public was saying about him these
women were so unaware that Ed Kemper was
a murderer that they would even have a
conversation with him about this co-ed
killer speculating about his motivations
he would hang out at the jury room bar
to learn new information about the case
he also watched a lot of crime shows on
TV in order to understand every possible
way that they might catch up to him for
example he had the urge to go to the
funerals of his victims and pays
respects but when he saw the detectives
always show up to the funeral of a
homicide victim he knew not to give in
to these natural impulses On February
the 5th 1973 he got into a very intense
argument with his mother and he went out
and killed two more girls
Rosalind Thorpe and Allison loomed he
finally made the connection that the
anger he felt towards his mother was the
trigger that set him off on this killing
spree he knew that if he wanted the
killings to stop he would need to kill
his mother but this plan would be put on
hold when the police showed up at the
Kemper residence
[Music]
a few days earlier the police received a
tip that Ed camber had purchased gun the
shop owner could see that his personal
record had been expunged and that he had
committed a murder when he was under 18
the shop owner reported it to the police
and gave them bed Kemper's name and
address when the police showed up they
recognized ed Kemper from the bar so
they assured him that it was just
formality it led them to his closet
where he kept several guns sitting next
to those weapons was a woman's purse and
a box filled with mementos from his
victims before the police officers took
notice he quickly distracted them and
led them out to his car where he had
more hidden weapons they did not suspect
him of being the murderer but he was
very paranoid and he was convinced that
they were on to him for an entire week
he planned his mother's murder when she
came home it was late at night and ed
Kemper woke up to hear stumble through
the front door at four o'clock in the
morning it was at this point that he
smashed her head in with a claw hammer
he then decapitated her sexually
violated her face and ripped out her
vocal cords shoving them in the garbage
disposal
then he placed her head on the
mantelpiece and started throwing dance
at it when his rage subsided he realized
that he had to make it look like a
break-in otherwise the police might
suspect him he called up his mother's
best friend Sally Hollis and said that
he had made a dinner for them both when
she arrived he strangled her
he then stuffed their bodies into a
closet and left and no for the police
after killing his mother the torment
stopped he packed his bags and drove far
far away he was able to actually start
speaking to women without fantasizing
about killing them because the source of
his anger it was gone but he realized he
couldn't live with the guilt any longer
and he actually wanted to stop hiding
and pay for his crimes he found the
nearest pay phone to call and confess
that he was the co-ed killer he waited
patiently there for them to arrive on
the ride back he gave the police
officers every little detail of his
crimes and the police officers felt sick
from listening to him when he was in
custody at Kemper openly admitted that
he could not control these delusions
that had taken over his mind he begged
for a lobotomy so that he never had the
urge to kill anyone ever again
that never happens he was sentenced to
10 counts of first-degree murder he is
still alive today and he's currently
spending life in prison in his time
behind bars he has shown a sense of
remorse for his crimes and he gladly
assisted in the research on the
psychology of serial killers by agreeing
to video and
audio interviews he also began to teach
classes in computer literacy to fellow
inmates and he has since spoken very
eloquently meme has even started reading
audio books for the blind since he was
always so polite and on his best
behavior he was allowed to leave prison
and to live in a reformed hospital most
psychiatrists who listened to the tapes
of Ed Kemper describing his life
believed that his mother must have had
borderline personality disorder ins if
it were not for all of the abuse that he
endured he would never have become a
serial killer others say that he was
just born a sociopath and that killing a
meant nothing to him
they believe that any sign of guilt or
remorse is simply just for show because
it was so good at studying real human
emotion matter what the truth behind at
campus mental state maybe none of it
justifies what happened to his victims
and it will never bring back the lives
of the women that he killed if we can
learn anything from the story of Ed
Kemper it's that we never truly know
what goes on inside the minds of the
people that we see every day
you just might never know that that kind
man next door is a serial killer so I
really hope you enjoyed the video if you
did please do hit that thumbs up button
below and don't forget to subscribe
we've got brand new videos several times
a week so subscribe hit that
notification bell you'll find out all
about those and as always thank you for
watching